one of my favorite things is when the
conspiracy theorists agree about the
conspiracy but with conflicting evidence
to support it this happens with flat
earthers all the time you've got flat
earthers who believe the Earth is flat
but they will prove quote prove the
Earth is flat with contradictory of
quote evidence and one of them has to be
wrong and I just absolutely love it and
we have an example from CPAC as many of
you know one of the big lie election
conspiracy theories is that
um part of how Democrats quote cheat is
with early voting and mail-in voting and
so there's a lot of Republicans who say
we just we've got to have one day of
voting and if you're a republican
definitely vote on Election Day so that
they don't mess with your vote but there
are others in the Republican Party who
are now realizing wait a second if the
Democrats vote early and by mail and we
don't they get like three weeks of
voting and we get one day that's not
good so here we have a clip uh Steve
Bannon and MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell
interviewing being interviewed whatever
and it starts to happen that there's
this disagreement wait are we is the
problem that we're not voting early or
should we or not this is this is just
absolute gold of the it's an example of
the mayonnaise that their brains have
been turned into game day voting yes
Steve we're going to get wiped out again
you cannot give the Democrats 55 days to
vote and we have 15 hours there's no
mathematical equation that is going to
win you an election it's great to talk
about it's fun you get fired up they've
got 55 days to get balance in and we're
giving ourselves 15 hours if we continue
this we'll never win again now
I don't think this guy's wrong in the
sense that
there is no voter fraud the way they
claim there is
and if you do restrict yourself only to
the people who can vote on Election Day
whereas Democrats are saying I'll vote
when it's convenient if there's early
voting I'll do that or I'll mail in by
ballot you are hurting yourself that is
true is it isn't that what they did to
Kerry Lake we had the camera that's why
they had to turn the machines off Steve
and they if they do it the way sin you
know he's just misconstrued you can't
overrun an algorithm and you can't
overrun a computer you have to do it the
way I'm telling you I like the woman in
the back nodding as if she has any idea
what pillow's talking about hold on hold
on here's where I propose in the war
rule do it rev we have to have a debate
on our side of the football because
there's clearly two camps and your
Camp's probably 65-35 but we need
everybody 100 on one or the other
because this is critical so we I commit
that we're going to do this when we get
everybody involved into town isn't this
the best they're going to hold a town
hall to argue should we use the methods
that the Democrats are using for fraud
or should we not but then we hurt
ourselves it it's unbelievable that
they're doing this to themselves said
every state is different their states
that John will be right in that's what
we're doing with the bureau we're
investing look at the footprint of the
state and what's the best thing to do in
that state some of these states uh
um you can vote a week early like in
Texas they don't have a lot of time to
pull from border rules Ah that's so so
pillow now is coming up with a sort of
new conspiracy theory which is listen in
states where there isn't much early
voting there it's okay to vote early
because they don't have time to execute
the fraud that they can do with the
machines when you vote like really early
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines so then later
pillow was interviewed by right side
broadcasting and now he is calling this
the new big lie now let me tell you the
big lie the new big lie yeah okay and
this comes from Republicans
and it's most of it's the establishment
but there's a few people in our in here
that still that they've because of what
happened in Arizona they believe this
what happened is everyone's saying and
this is like even the RNC when I was
there running for the chair they're
going
um we've got to do like the Democrats
vote early look what happened in Arizona
what if something goes wrong with the
machine we got to vote early on ballot
Harvest and and drop boxes and you know
if you can't fight them join them if you
do that we lose our country we have
fought two years to do same day born and
get rid of these machines two years
you're going to destroy everything we've
fought for now the funny thing is pillow
has been fighting for two years but
they're not any closer to getting rid of
early voting and mail-in voting this is
fantastic and this is the exact type of
fight that we should allow them to have
amongst themselves well we just remember
hey let's vote let's let's vote however
it is because these stories about
widespread election fraud have not been
substantiated in the least but we want
them wasting their time with this sort
of nonsense because it's a black hole
for them it's a complete and total black
hole hold Town Halls do all of it argue
about whether or not to vote early
meanwhile we'll just keep trying to get
people registered and convincing people
about the importance of voting in the
first place